we were promised to Battle Star
Galactica movie and television series
but it looks like both are dead in the
water
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV
movie channel
[Music]
NBC Universal have been trying to get us
a battle Star galactor movie for
bloodies but we're still waiting it
hasn't happened yet currently though on
IMDb The Battlestar Galactica reboot
movie is still listed as an active
project for Simon kingberg with quite a
few other projects I have to say
um the lift is a producer Haunting of
Venice is an executive producer Deadpool
3 is a producer sugar as an executive
producer the Weyland project as a
producer Here Comes the Flood The
Running Man Artemis Necromancer Luna
Park Osterman weekend rust the caves of
Steel but either actually it goes on
and on Logan's Run that'll be
interesting uh Battlestar galactico
towards the bottom I am not alone it
just goes on and on and on a project
called red shirt
beware the Star Trek movie where
everyone dies probably
my point there being that Simon kingberg
is a very busy producer he has lots of
projects on his slate and Battlestar
Galactica looks like it's no longer one
of them the movie currently is not a
priority for Universal
and I am being told by people that
working around the industry that it's
not going to happen anytime soon that a
reboot a hard reboot of the Battlestar
Galactica story for the big screen is
still a distinct possibility
but not anytime soon this was a project
that was actually supposed to be in the
cinemas this year
but thanks to covid and then just a
change in priorities for Universal it
doesn't look like we're getting the
movie now that movie was supposed to be
a hard reboot retelling of the original
story so it would be the attack from the
cylons the Galactica and a fleet of
colonial vessels escaping and trying to
survive the onslaught
just want you to keep that in mind as I
tell you about the Sam Ismail plan for
the TV series The NBC over at peacock
were also going to be producing so this
got green lit in 2019
just before covid like so many other
projects that are now stuck in
development help but samsmail has
updated us a couple of times since and
he said that this project was still on
the cards and it was still happening he
says that this series was going to be
done with a Synergy between the series
and the movie that they were going to
share a universe and 100 percent he
tweeted this would not be a reboot of
Ronald D Moore's Battlestar Galactica
because why mess with perfection now
Colony confused but how can the movie be
a hard reboot this TV series be done
with in Synergy of it but not be hard
reboot
never did quite get my head around that
but I think it does show that there's an
element of confusion around these
projects even from day one they didn't
really quite know what they were
actually wanting to do with the
Battlestar Galactica franchise they
didn't even seem to know what they were
being asked to do by the studios what
kingberg and esmail were saying didn't
make sense from day one and now it looks
like that that confusion has led to
cancellation because it doesn't look
like we're going to be getting the TV
series or the movie like I say but why
has this happened
partly it's covered partly it was
happened that these things were greenlit
in 2019 and then basically the world
stopped for 18 months
that's not helped several projects you
know obviously here on soundtrack and if
you're a regular sound tracker we talk
about Stargate a lot if it wasn't for
kovid we'd currently be on our third
season of Brad Wright's Stargate return
just think about that for a second we'd
have at least watched three seasons
already we'd be looking forward to our
fourth with Brad Wright at the helm
covid took a lot away from us
but the fact they've took Stargate away
from me with Brad Wright really stinks
unfortunately it seems to have had a
similar impact to Battlestar Galactica
they really really were pushing for this
project and Sam Ismail has lost people
along the way a couple of the co-writers
and producers that were signed on in
2019 have moved on to other projects it
really is Sam on his own but even though
Sam is looking at moving on to other
projects as well a person that works
really closely with a big marketing
agency in Hollywood said that there was
conversations between Sam and the
production company about six months ago
he apparently Sam at that point was
still hopeful it was supposed to have
started by now now very recently within
the last couple of weeks there was
another meeting between Sam Ismail and
this similar production company and they
were talking about marketing some other
projects as some Ismail has been
involved in Battlestar Galactica was
mentioned and Sam Ismail said we just
need to put that at the back of the list
for now now that is not a straight-up
cancellation but in terms of Hollywood
and the way Hollywood works it really
means it's stuck in development hell it
really means that it's not going to be
happening this year 100 and it probably
isn't going to happen anytime soon or
definitely not at very least with the
people currently attached
so Sam Ismail who brought us Mr Robot a
great series I absolutely adored is
probably not going to get a crack at the
whip of Battlestar Galactica now I could
actually see that when the Battlestar
Galactica movie finally gets made the
Kimber will probably be involved because
as you can see from the list of movies
Etc he's producing right now he's
producing everything so why wouldn't he
be
but some Ismail
you've missed your chance
guys get the comments don't tell me what
you think about this news that we're
almost certainly not going to be getting
the Battlestar Galactica reboot we were
promised was it a confused project from
day one that was doomed to fail because
let's be honest look we've all worked in
offices and jobs and things like that
when a new project comes along and the
bosses are telling you about it and you
can't quite figure out what the hell
they're talking about or it doesn't
really quite make sense it's very clear
that there isn't a plan
and when there isn't a plan these
projects seem to be doomed to fail
against the comments tell me exactly
what you think if you are new to the
Channel please like subscribe hit that
Bell notification it really helps us out
and you'll never miss any of our new
videos also you can go to patreon.com
forward slash Sidetrack where most of
our new videos appear first and for a
small contribution each month that
really supports the channel you can see
them first and without any of the
adverts
as always please stay safe I'll see you
next time
foreign
[Music]